Çeviri: berat güven
Gözden geçirme: Suleyman Cengiz
Hepinize merhabalar.
Vallahi, çok ilham verici bir
konuşmadan sonra
ben hasetten söz edeceğim.
(Kahkahalar)
Gerçi, çok haset ettim, çünkü
benim hasetim de balerin olmaktı,
ama bale derslerine göndermediler beni.
Özellikle, öyle böyle değil,
Pina Bausch'un balerini olmak isitiyordum.
Belki bir dahaki hayatımda olurum.
Şimdi benim konuşmam...
Ben kuvvetli duyguları çok seviyorum:
Kızgınlık, haset, rekabet, macera gibi.
Onları irdelemek, anlamak
ve sadece yıkıcı taraflarını değil,
bunların ilham verici
ve yapıcı taraflarını
çok merak ediyorum.
O nedenle, kendi haset
yolculuğumdan başlayayım.
Şimdi, benim her zaman saçlarım
çok cılız oldu.
Bugün, bakmayın kuaföre gittim.
Her zaman böyle
cılız, çelimsiz saçlarım oldu
ve okula - ilkokul değil de -
çocukluk arkadaşım Oya,
resimde görüldüğü gibi,
harika güzel örgüleri vardı.
Altın başak, kolum kadar kalın örgüler
ve ben hasetten çatlıyordum.
Üstelik, saçını at kuyruğu yapıyor,
arkasından güzel bir örgü yapıyor.
İki tane yanından örgüler. Anneme gittim
dedim ki, "Ben de örgü istiyorum."
"Peki kızım" dedi annem.
İki tane örgü yaptı.
Örgülerim fare kuyruğu gibi,
iki yandan yukarı kalkıyor.
Tabii çok masumdum.
Derken okuldayım;
önümdeki sırada Mina,
iki tane altın sarısı örgü,
eğiliyor, çantasından bir şey alıyor,
o örgüler şöyle sarkıyor, Mina dikiliyor,
saçlarını arkasına atıyor
ve ben ders dinleyeceğime
sadece ve sadece örgüleri izliyorum.
Ders filan yok ve hasetten çatlıyorum.
Ne yaptım sizce?
(Seyirci cevapları)
Efendim?
Saçını kestim?
Başka?
(Seyirci cevapları)
Nasıl?
Kendi saçımı?
(Seyirci cevapları)
Başka?
Nasıl? (kahkaha) sakız yapıştırdım?
Evet bütün bunlar, mesela veya çimdikledim
veya saçını çektim.
Ben, sekiz dokuz yaşlarındaydım.
Eve gittim, o yaşımda.
Annemin bir dikiş kutusu vardı.
İçinde iki tane perde püskülü, bordo!
Birer toka aldım, bir tanesini
bu tarafıma, bir tanesini bu tarafıma.
Ders masasına oturuyorum,
tabii silgimi itekliyorum,
silgim düşüyor,
eğiliyorum, iki tane paralel örgü
arkama atıyorum.
(Kahkaha ve alkışlar)
Ve bir ay kadar ben, böyle bir, hasetimi
tuhaf, o yaşımdaki yaratıcılıkla giderdim.
Bir gün babam eve erken geldi.
Ben de koşarak kapıyı açtım.
Örgüler.
"Kızım, sen Kızılderili misin nesin?
Çıkar çabuk bu örgüleri" dedi.
Annem örgüleri almış yani püskülleri.
Ağlamıştım epey.
Yok etti.
Bu benim haset yolculuğumun başlangıcı.
Şimdi bir bakalım;
haset ve kıskançlık ayrı şeyler.
Haset bir eksiklik: Onda var, bende yok.
Kıskançlık bir kayıp,
yani var olanı kaybediyorum.
Haset diyor ki "Ben bunu istiyorum."
Kıskançlık diyor ki
"Var olanı geri istiyorum."
Yani, annenin sevgisini, dikkatini
alıyorum, kardeş geliyor,
kardeşe bölündüğü için
kıskanmaya başlıyorum.
Dolayısıyla hasette iki kişi var,
kıskançlıkta üç kişi var.
Lacan der ki "Haset bir eksiklik
duygusundan kaynaklanır."
Onda var bende yok ve bu eksiklik
ya gerçektir ya da yanılgıdır.
Mesela diyelim ki
başarılıyım, iyi gidiyor.
Çok başarılı bir arkadaşım gelir,
meslektaşım gelir, parlak, çok iyi,
kendimi başarısız hissederim onun yanında.
Aslında gerçek değil, yanılgı.
Nedir? Haset ediyorum, bir şeyler
yapıyor. Anlatacağım zaten.
Dolayısıyla kıskançlık,
olanı kaybetme korkusu:
Sevgi, dikkat, özen, statü, dostluk.
Arkadaşınız vardır,
yeni bir arkadaş gelir,
dikkat ona gider, kıskanmaya başlarız.
Şimdi haset, bir bağ var.
Haset ettiğimiz zaman
aklımız sabit fikir hâlinde
haset ettiğimiz kişiye takılıyor.
"O ne yapardı? Böyle bir durumda
o ne derdi?" gibi
ve saplantı hâlinde zihnimize yerleşiyor.
İşte Oya'nın saçları.
Gerçekten saplantı halinde kafamdaydı.
Hâlâ çok severim uzun saçlı kadınları.
Şimdi, öznel bir haset ölçeği oluyor
sanki haset ettiğim insan
çok büyük ve yüce,
ben de kendimi pire gibi hissediyorum.
Melanie Klein bu konuda çok yazmış.
"Haset ve Şükran" kitabı çok tanınmıştır.
Bir güdü, haset edilen kişiye bir zarar
vermek istiyoruz, onu yok etmek istiyoruz.
Nitekim sizlerden de geldi "saçını kestin,
sakız yapıştırdın" gibi
zarar verme güdüsü.
Hani içimizde "şeytanların dansı"
- bu Siyah kalem'in bir çizimi -
içimizde çok güçlü duygular savaşıyor.
Ve negatif enerji kullanımı.
Haset ettiğim kişiyi
bastırmaya çalışıyorum,
onu küçük göstermeye çalışıyorum.
Mesela dedikodu ediyorum,
kötü şeyler söylüyorum.
Fakat, şöyle bakalım:
Duygular bize mesaj verir
ve hasette bir sorun yok,
o duyguda bir sorun yok.
Onu nasıl kullandığımızda sorun var.
Kızgınlık da aynı şey.
Kızgınlık bir mesaj veriyor.
Onu nasıl kullandığımız.
Saldırgan da kullanabiliriz,
ifade için de kullanabiliriz.
Dolayısıyla sorun hasette değil.
Sorun duygusal enerjinin
kullanım şeklinde,
çünkü duygular bizi enerjiyle yükler.
Şimdi, size bir fıkra anlatayım:
Adam ölmüş, öbür dünyaya gitmiş.
Öbür dünyada, demişler ki
senin günahların var
ama sana bir kıyak çekelim,
cehennemlerden seç.
Ya yerli cehenneme gideceksin
ya da yabancı cehenneme gideceksin.
Adam demiş ki, ben yabancıya
gideyim, daha garanti.
Gitmiş, bakmış, koca bir kazan;
içinde fokur fokur kaynıyor bir pis su.
İnsanlar bağırıyor, çağırıyor:
Kurtar beni.
Bir de cehennem zebanisi, elinde
bir tane kocaman kepçe.
Başını kim sudan çıkarırsa küt kafasına!
Adamın ödü kopmuş. Demiş ki,
hiç sevmedim burasını,
ben yerli cehenneme gideyim.
Gitmiş; yerli cehennemde bir kazan,
içinde pis bir su.
İnsanlar bağırıyor, çağırıyor,
cehennem zebanisi yok!
Allah Allah? Demiş ki,
burada niye cehennem zebanisi yok?
Eh, işsizlikten. Nasıl yani?
Niye işsiz?
Burada, yerli şeyde gerekmiyor;
zaten kim kafasını çıkarırsa
ötekiler ayağından aşağıya çekiyorlar.
Dolayısıyla haset böyle bir şey;
ayağından aşağı çekmek başını çıkaranı.
Demek ki haset ya yıkıcı kullanılabilir
veya yapıcı kullanılabilir.
Nasıl?
Ya reaktif, tepkisel
veya proaktif, yaratıcı.
Yani şöyle diyebiliriz;
haset bir gelişim mesajı olabilir.
Burada yine kendi
yolculuğumla devam edeyim.
Şimdi ben otuz küsur senedir
bu meslekteyim.
Çok sevdiğim bir meslektaşım,
Sevil, İsveç'ten geliyor.
Geliyor anlatmaya başlıyor:
"İşte şöyle bir eğitime gittim.
Otto Kernberg'in seminerine gittim."
Ben tırnaklarımı yiyorum, cızz!
Çünkü o sıralarda, özellikle o sıralarda,
o kadar kaliteli eğitimler Türkiye'de yok.
Ne yaptım?
Efendim?
(dinleyici cevapları)
Ne yaptım?
Şeyde kaldım...
Evet! Ben ne yaptığımı
söyleyeyim. Tabii ki!
Bu eğitimler nerede oluyor diye,
gitmeye başladım.
Araştırdım. O zaman
internet de yoktu, araştırdım
ve bu seminerlere ve kongrelere
katılmaya başladım.
Para topladım, eğitimime yatırdım.
Ve o seminer ve kongrelerde
beni tutan, beğenen birkaç meslektaşım
beni, Uluslararası Grup Psikoterapileri
Kongresi'ne davet ettiler.
Sonra, tuttukları için beni
yönetim kuruluna aldılar.
On sene boyunca yönetim kurulunda
üye olarak aktif çalıştım.
Derken Amerikan Grup
Psikoterapileri Kongresi,
tam yanı başımızda,
bütün toplantılarda.
Bakıyorum harika kongreler var.
O kongrelere katılmaya başladım.
Bir haftalık, çok uzun çalışmalar.
Şimdi, açılış oluyor.
Açılış konuşmasında
önce haftalık programı sunuyorlar,
sonra sunum yapanların
isimleriyle birlikte o toplulukta ayağa
kalkmaları istiyorlar, bin kişi!
Ve ben o ayağa kalkanlara bakıyorum
ve cızz! Tabii anladım.
Dedim "Ben buraya haset ediyorsam
demek ki sunum yapmak istiyorum."
Tamam, ertesi gün bir sunum
özeti gönderdim. Hangi konuda?
Haset!
Haset konusunda sunum gönderdim
ve ikişer günlük.
Hele o Amerikalı meslektaşlarım,
piranha gibi insanı yerler.
Onlarla haset ve rekabet konusunda
grup çalışmaları yapmaya başladım
ve inanır mısınız, şu anda o topluluk
içinde, hasetin referans kişisi oldum.
Ve de, bu konuda kitap yazdım.
Türkçe de kitap yazdım.
Yani, hasetimi bir gelişim mesajı olarak
kullanmayı öğrendim.
Dolayısıyla, özenip haset
ettiğimiz şey aslında
haset ettiğimiz kişiden çok
kendimiz hakkında bir ayna.
Bana bir şey söylüyor bu duygu.
Haset ne veriyor?
Hayranlık, gıpta, güdülenme, ivme,
motivasyon, ilham veriyor
ve o ilhamı enerji
gücüyle kullanabilirsiniz.
Hasetin insanı harekete
geçiren, kışkırtan,
yaşam ve mücadeleye iteleyen bir gücü var.
Hasete ben "hasret" diyorum.
Hasret duyduğum şeye
haset ediyorum aslında,
çünkü onu kendimde istiyorum.
Haset ve arzu aslında bilinçaltı
bir tango yaparlar.
Ve de bu ikili, dolunayın karanlık ve
aydınlık yüzleri gibidir.
Dolunayın karanlık yüzü eğer hasetse,
aydınlık yüzü de arzu ve tutku.
Ayşede ne kadar tutku var,
ne kadar güzel!
Haset, dediğimiz gibi,
gerçekleştiremediğimiz potansiyelimizin
başkasında gördüğümüz bir aynasıdır.
Yani kendimi pire gibi hissediyorsam,
yücelttiğim kişiyle aramdaki mesafe
aslında kendimi geliştirme alanı.
Ve o zaman pozitif enerji ne demek?
Haset ettiğim kişiyi düşüneceğime,
ona nasıl saldırganlık yapacağımı
düşüneceğime,
düşünce gücümü kendime çeviririm
ve kendimi yüceltmeye çalışırım.
Çünkü hasetin acı veren iğnesi
aslında balımı çıkarıyor.
Haset bizi bir kaktüs gibi
dikenli yapar
ve aslında kaktüsün kökleri
kendini geliştirme isteği,
motivasyon, mücadele arzusu,
biricik olma isteği, hırs, tutku,
fark edilme isteği, ivme isteği,
gelişmemiş potansiyel, başarı arzusu
ve zorluklarla baş etme,
"challenge" arıyoruz.
Ne kadar doyum alıp, kendimize
yönelip kendimizi geliştirirsek
öz güvenimiz o kadar yükselir,
haset o kadar düşer.
Ters orantılıdır öz güven ve haset.
Eğer haset yoksa depresif duygular var.
Yalnız karanlık yüzünü yaşıyoruz mehtabın.
Halbuki arzumuza bakarsak
ve tutkumuza bakarsak
ve ona doğru kendimize izin verirsek,
gerçekten de bir tango oluşur.
Yoksa, mitolojideki kendi kuyruğunu
yiyen yılan gibi oluruz.
Kendi gücümüzü yiyerek,
sadece kısır döngülerde kalırız.
O nedenle Jessamyn West demiş ki,
"Seni sokmayan engerek
sana hiçbir şey öğretemez"
Kaktüslerin de böyle çiçekleri var!
Teşekkürler.
(Alkışlar)